about what's going on
with this case.
'Cause I was very confused
by everything they were saying.
Oh, I wasn't confused
at all.
All right.
Talk -- Walk me through it.
So Bluebeard --
[ Laughing ] Yes.
Bluebeard had moved in
with Khaleesi.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
Okay,
that's the blonde chick.
I love it --
Kelsey Khaleesi.
That will be easy
for me to remember.
Yes, well,
he moved in with Khaleesi.
Mm-hmm.
And then Khaleesi
turned out to be ratchet.
Oh.
You got some lipstick on,
that's cute.
[ Both laugh ]
Sorry.
It's okay.
So -- So she turned out
to be a ratchet.
She liked
to have a gang of guys over,
and she was bringing over guys
that wasn't down with Bluebeard
'cause, see, Bluebeard,
he a pirate,
so he is, like, trying to find
people to move in or whatever.
Right.
And then
the other girl --
that's the girl
that he's suing, okay --
I'm gonna call her
the chick from --
um, what's that show
with Michael J. Fox?
Um...
"Family Ties"?
"Family Ties."
You think
she's Justine Bateman?!
The one
that looked like --
Mallory?!
All right.
Mallory.
I'll call her Mallory.
She's our Mallory.
She's Mallory,
all right, so she --
I'd watch a Khaleesi
and Mallory show.
Right?
In a heartbeat.
In a minute.
You kidding?
So, yeah, she's like,
"My roommate or whatever,
he don't like
the way I get down
'cause I be having dick
up in here
and none of the dick
want him."
Right.
And so
she tell her friend that,
and then she's like,
"Girl, I like dick, too.
Like,
what's up?"
And she's like, "Well,
you want to be my roommate?"
And she's like, "Yeah, but I
ain't got no deposit money."
And then they come over
to the house
like she want
to be the roommate,
and he like, "Okay, cool,
but I'm gonna need
that deposit money."
She like, "Well,
I don't have it right now,
but I get it
to you."
Right?
Right.
Now, when she said,
"I get it to you,"
she ain't say when
she was gonna get it to him,
but she gonna get it
to him, right?
Someday.
That means,
"Bitch, you got to pay."
Right.
Now, if you gonna make
$10 deposits or whatever,
however you gonna pay it,
you said you gonna pay it.
She did say
she was gonna pay it.